mesdames Messieurs chers amis merci
d'être venu si nombreux ici dans cette
belle ville de Beaucaire merci à son
maire cher Julien merci à vous tous
citoyens militants élus du rassemblement
national chers amis qui nous fêtent
l'honneur de votre présence et merci
surtout pour votre ferveur et pour votre
enthousiasme si communicatif cette
ferveur ces attentes si forte qui
émanent de vous sont sans doute le
meilleur antidote à un sentiment qui je
dois le dire mais totalement étranger la
résignation
merci Jordan
merci Jordan pour ton discours qui
décrit la situation difficile de notre
pays les nombreux sujets d'inquiétude
pour nos compatriotes au premier rang
desquels l'inflation et l'insécurité ton
discours a aussi rappelé qu'il n'y a pas
de fatalité et que notre pays possède
toutes les ressources pour se redresser
pour retrouver une puissance au service
des Français de l'Europe et du monde
je le disais encore il y a moins d'une
semaine à Hénin-Beaumont non seulement
vous donner un sens à mon combat et au
combat de tous les élus du rassemblement
national mais au-delà du sens vous nous
donnez une force sans égal pour vous
représenter et vous défendre au
Parlement pour porter nos idées nos
solutions et nos espoirs chaque jour
dans le débat public vous le savez chers
amis
et Jordan vient de le rappeler
nous entrons dans une année électorale
qui s'annonce décisive et c'est de votre
force précisément dont nous aurons
besoin pour nous porter jusqu'à cette
date qui désormais va occuper pendant
plusieurs mois nos esprits le 9 juin
[Applaudissements]
ce 9 juin 2024
vous avez raison on a 9 mois pour en
faire un jour de mobilisation
un de ces jours le peuple de France
relève la tête face à l'adversité un
rendez-vous démocratique dont nous
tous présents nous souviendrons de
longues années
tidons eux qui aiment désormais à
s'autodigineux sous le terme de bloc
central se souviendront comme celui d'un
nouveau réveil du peuple de France
[Applaudissements]
ce 9 juin
nous avons l'intention d'en faire un
jour de fierté et de ferveur même mes
chers amis il y a une condition
sinequanone pour que cela arrive
que le peuple de France aille voter et
il faudra impérativement voter et faire
voter
si vous ne le faites pas Emmanuel Macron
et ses amis bénéficieront par la par
défaut en réalité de l'appui d'un
Parlement européen à qui à leurs idées
pour poursuivre leur entreprise de
déconstruction affaiblir nos défenses
collectives et ouvrir nos frontières aux
menaces extérieures
et si nous y parvenons
quelque chose me dit qu'il nous
rappellera peut-être un autre jour de
juin
le 19 il y a à peine plus d'un an où
nous avons envoyé des joues en tous les
pronostics près d'une centaine de
députés à l'Assemblée nationale
[Applaudissements]
alors que de chemin parcouru depuis
chers amis je suis certaine que comme
moi il vous semble que c'était déjà il y
a un siècle ce 9 juin 2024 enfin nous
voulons en faire le jour de l'ambition
nationale plus que jamais confiante et
conquérant un jour de sursaut ou la
nation française
proclamera de nouveau avec ferveur son
désir de liberté la liberté des citoyens
et des nations la liberté des hommes et
des peuples la liberté des intelligences
et des esprits c'est tout l'enjeu du
prochain scrutin européen
c'est un enjeu pour les Français en
France
pour les Français en Europe et pour tous
les peuples d'Europe quelle belle cause
pour notre peuple que celle de sa
liberté à se déterminer de son droit à
l'émancipation par le choix démocratique
ne l'oublions jamais
aux origines
francs signifie avant tout libre
ce n'est donc pas pour rien que notre
peuple fait preuve d'une si grande
aspiration à la liberté et plus encore
lorsqu'il sent que l'on veut le conduire
comme c'est le cas de la technocratie
bruxellesoise à une forme de servitude
le premier emblème de cette servitude
c'est bien évidemment la Commission
européenne elle-même Madame Van der
leyenne a beau se rêver en chef d'un
nouvel État fédéral imposé aux nations
du continent elle incarne de fait aucune
souveraineté
et ce sont pourtant les milliers de
technocrates bruxellois qui exercent
chaque année à droite veto de
commentaires de jugement sur les choix
des gouvernements de nos pays
qui empêche par exemple l'émergence de
champion industriels européens pendant
que notre production industrielle et
notre balance commerciale s'effondre
le deuxième emblème de cette servitude
c'est la façon dont les peuples des
nations européennes ont été peu à peu
hors de tout contrôle démocratique
dépossédés de droits de liberté et de
choix qu'il croyait pourtant garanti par
leurs différentes constitutions
cette déposition elle a été opérée par
le jeu de la jurisprudence des instances
européennes qui progressivement se sont
arrosés des pouvoirs exorbitants elle
s'est opérée aussi par des référendum
ignorés puis bafouer comme celui de 2005
qui restera dans l'histoire de la 5e
République comme le pire déni de
démocratie
[Musique]
le troisième enveloppe de emblème de
cette servitude c'est enfin l'état de
minorité juridique presque d'enfance
dans lequel nous a peu à peu placé
l'extension des pouvoirs de l'Union
européenne en piétant systématiquement
sur le pouvoir des états des accords de
libre-échange anachroniques ont continué
d'être signé depuis 20 ans au mépris de
la protection de nos entreprises et de
nos agriculteurs au mépris aussi du
combat contre le réchauffement
climatique il est plus facile il est
vrai
de faire fonctionner les micros
[Applaudissements]
il est plus facile il est vrai de
matraquer les consommateurs européens de
taxes sur les carburants que d'imposer
la volonté souveraine des états face aux
intérêts de firmes mondialisés qui
détruisent notre planète
et comment ne pas évoquer alors que de
nouvelles images
dramatiquement inquiétante nous viennent
de lampée douza cette directive
européenne qui ont peu à peu imposer une
répartition autoritaire de flux
migratoires hors de contrôle
demain ce sont des sanctions financières
qui seront imposées grâce aux pactes
européens sur les migration au pays
récalcitrants mais quelle honte
[Musique]
nous devons rester totalement maître de
notre politique d'immigration et j'irai
même plus loin
il est 20 d'en appeler à l'Union
européenne pour résoudre la crise
migratoire comme un enfant appelle maman
quand il a un problème
c'est 20 et c'est dangereux
c'est 20 mes amis parce que l'Union
européenne a fait de l'agence Frontex
non pas un corps de garde de frontière
mais une agence d'hotesse d'accueil de
l'immigration anarchique
c'est dangereux
c'est dangereux parce que
cette actée que c'est à l'Union
européenne de décider de notre politique
migratoire or c'est à nous et à nous
serrer
dois-je
dois-je également rappeler chers amis
comment le dogmatisme concurrentiel
européen
ami et continue de mettre en péril des
milliers d'entreprises et des millions
de ménages français contraint de subir
les fluctuations anarchiques des prix
liés au marché européen de l'électricité
soyons bien conscients que les juges qui
nous entravent ne sont pas le fait d'une
quelconque fatalité mais bien de
l'acheter et même souvent de volonté
ils ne sont pas le fait de l'Europe qui
est une réalité
ils sont le fait de cette union
européenne qui cherche telle un empire à
uniformiser par la contrainte notre
vieux continent au lieu de créer les
conditions d'une coopération
bienfaisante entre nations libre la
coopération bienfaisante entre nations
libre voilà ce qui devrait être le rêve
européen
et moi si vous saviez
aujourd'hui madame vanderleyen et sa
corps de rocrates abîme jour après jour
ce rêve entraînant d'ailleurs se
réveille des peuples que nous voyons
points des nations européennes et bien
mes amis il nous faut accompagner ce
réveil il nous faut retrouver ce rêve
européen en mettant à la première place
la volonté des peuples et la diversité
des nations parce que
comme la rappeler Jordan ce qui nous est
imposé c'est aussi au-delà de la
structure bruxelloise une soumission à
l'idéologie du renoncement c'est
l'arrimage de la France a un projet de
déconstruction
l'acceptation de l'effondrement de nos
potentiels l'abdication à toute idée de
puissance
Jordan tu l'as dit tout à l'heure
face
coûtait déjà il pleut pas
face tu disais face aux forces du
renoncement qui vont de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon à Emmanuel Macron nous devons
rassembler les partisans de la puissance
c'est-à-dire tous ceux qui pensent que
la France est encore une grande nation
avec une identité millénaire une culture
un génie des frontières et une
prospérité à conquérir
et en effet
qui
qui sinon les nations
pourra éviter que demain se reproduisent
aux frontières de la Chine qui redessine
d'autorité ces frontières une tragédie
similaire à celle que villes Ukraine
depuis un an et demi du fait de
l'agression russe
nous assistons un puissant à des sommets
internationaux les éléments de langage
creux et les sanctions
inefficaces sont égrégnées en réalité
seuls les nations souveraines dans la
France au premier chef aurait la
capacité d'asseoir à la table des
négociations la Russie et l'Ukraine et à
mettre fin un terme enfin au martyrs du
peuple ukrainien
qui
sinon les nations pourra protéger demain
les peuples du monde contre la prédation
croissante que font peser les milices
qu'elle soit terroristes ou
para-étatiques mais à cet égard la
politique enfin ou plutôt la non
politique d'Emmanuel Macron en Afrique
et l'une des incarnations les plus
manifestes de l'échec du
multilatéralisme creux
en déléguant mes amis à l'Union
européenne notre diplomatie nous nous
sommes nation française coulaient dans
sa vision du monde une vision
irrespectueuse des identités nationales
qui ne convainc pas mais impose
contraint menace et culpabilise et nous
l'avons laissé s'éteindre cette voix
spécifique qui est celle de la France
dans le concert des nations la facture
mes amis n'a pas tardé à arriver
en multipliant les instances de dialogue
sans pouvoir réel dans la bande saelo
saharienne c'est en réalité la force des
liens affectifs et historiques si
particulier qui unissait la France à ces
États souverains que sont le Burkina
Faso la Côte d'Ivoire ou le Niger que le
président a détruite et je le dis si
seul en allemand la réparation de ces
liens sera un chantier important lorsque
nous serons au pouvoir car c'est en
Afrique que se joue une part une part
mais une part essentielle du rayonnement
culturel et économique de notre grande
et belle France
qui
qui sinon les nations pourra réellement
préserver les peuples du monde demain et
pour le siècle qui vient de l'impact
toujours croissant du réchauffement
climatique et de ses conséquences déjà
perceptibles sur les flux de population
incontrôlées qui menacent à la fois on
est obligé de le constater nos modes de
vie et la paix civile dans nombre
d'États européens encore une fois ce
sont pas les forums les cops les sommets
qui pourront répondre à ces
problématiques dont les solutions sont
si profondément nationales qui pourront
opérer ces choix qui relèvent de la plus
stricte intimité des peuples
le modèle énergétique français n'a pas à
être décidé par des hauts fonctionnaires
allemands espagnols ou hollandais en
poste à Bruxelles
qui
sinon les nations pourront enfin
protéger les citoyens des États les plus
avancés mais aussi demain ceux des
paysans envoient de développement des
menaces que fait peser sur eux la
croissance exponentielle de technologie
toujours plus intrusive toujours plus
opaque toujours moins contrôlé par les
instances supranationales soi-disant
d'ailleurs chargé de leur régulation
mais l'actualité récente nous a montré
qu’un milliardaire Elon Musk pouvait
influer à lui seul sur le cours d'une
guerre inter-étatique en désactivant des
réseaux satellitaires hors de tout
contrôle public
les gafams aussi leur puissance de leur
poids financiers il pèse d'ailleurs plus
lourd que le PIB de nombre de pays du
monde ce qui était inenvisageable il y a
encore quelques décennies pour une
entité commerciale
dans le même temps nous nous rappelons
tous comment la commission finalement
rattrapée par les mois justifiés
d'ailleurs de l'opinion a dû renoncer à
nommer une ancienne nobiste des gafams
comme chef économiste en charge de la
concurrence rien que cela une fois
encore le contournement des
souverainetés nationales au nom d'une
régulation multilatérale et non
démocratique soi-disant plus efficace
n'est que le faune d'un logiciel
mondialiste aux abois
oui chers amis ce combat pour les
peuples et les nations a toujours été
celui de la France des Capétiens à la
République de Philippe Auguste général
de Gaulle c'est ce combat qui depuis des
siècles donne à la France cette place si
singulière dans le concert des nations
c'est ce combat qui hier faisait dire
non à la guerre en Irak et qui
avant-hier soutenait la création des
États-Unis d'Amérique ce combat est
toujours d'une impérieuse actualité pour
la France il est vitale pour l'Europe il
est nécessaire pour le monde il sera
apaisant
voilà pourquoi
je formule aujourd'hui devant vous le
souhait que soit promu dans les mois et
les années à venir une déclaration
solennelle du droit des peuples et des
nations qui marquera la fin du funeste
processus d'uniformisation et de
dissolution conduit depuis 50 ans
tout comme les idéologies barbares du
20e siècle ont entraîné une prise de
conscience tragique de la communauté
internationale en 1945 et peu après la
naissance de la Déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme je suis convaincu
que l'effondrement des illusions
mondialistes appelent dans le temps
présent la création de nouvelles
protections pour les libertés humaines
et la pluralité des cultures nationales
pour que les aspirations des peuples et
des nations se concrétisent de manière
pacifique et ordonnées il apparaît
nécessaire de faire appel aux droits et
de donner à la communauté internationale
un outil supplémentaire pour je cite la
Charte de l'ONU favoriser le progrès
social et instauré les meilleurs
conditions de vie dans une liberté plus
grande nous avons au rassemblement
national rédigé un projet de texte en ce
sens il vous sera distribué tout à
l'heure je formule le vœu
je formule le vœu que cette déclaration
que je vais vous présenter brièvement
irrigue le projet que nous porterons
dans le cadre des élections européennes
fondamentalement il s'agit non seulement
d'un acte de foi dans la force des
Nations mais surtout la proclamation de
nouveaux droits venant compléter les
règles internationales au premier rang
desquels la Déclaration universelle des
droits de l'homme
en effet si celle-ci vise à protéger les
hommes et des citoyens contre les abus
de leur propre état il s'agit maintenant
de compléter ses droits fondamentaux des
personnes par la sacralisation des
droits des nations et des peuples sans
lesquels je vous le dis très clairement
les droits individuels ne peuvent
s'épanouir sans lesquelles il n'existe
plus réellement de liberté des peuples à
disposer d'eux-mêmes
la vision que nous portons à travers ce
texte est résumé en 16 articles qui
gravent les droits inaliénables des
nations être et demeurer être respecté
dans leur liberté et leur particularité
par ce texte nous entendons souhaité
nous entendons pardon défendre la
dignité et l'égalité des nations en
droit à rebourser des désirs
hégémoniques de quelques grandes
puissances étatiques ou supranational
dont bien sûr l'Union européenne est une
incarnation à rebours également de la
logique de bloc dans laquelle la folie
de quelques-uns veulent nous entraîner
par ce texte nous souhaitons aussi
défendre la souveraineté je vous dis
souvent que la souveraineté est aux
nations ce que la liberté est aux
individus
plus jamais nous ne devons tolérer que
l'on impose sur le sol européen des
modes de gouvernement ou des
législations à des chefs d'État qui ont
été élus démocratiquement et ce né en
Pologne né en gris né en Italie ni
ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
par ce texte
nous souhaitons défendre la légitimité
supérieure des constitutions nationales
la Constitution
n'appartient à personne d'autre qu'à
vous c'est votre constitution
et nous devons la défendre
[Applaudissements]
là voyez-vous des organisations et
autorités non élues ont pris l'habitude
depuis des décennies d'enfermer peu à
peu les États dans des carcans
juridiques supranationaux qui privent de
fait le choix démocratique d'être suivi
des effets attendus par les citoyens
le droit des peuples à se choisir des
règles supérieures communes doit être
réaffirmé il doit être aussi respecté
par ce texte nous souhaitons défendre la
sécurité des Nations en réaffirmant le
caractère incontournable du règlement
pacifique des conflits indispensables à
la stabilité du monde par ce texte nous
souhaitons affirmer notre attachement
aux droits pour chaque nation de
défendre ses intérêts vitaux au premier
chef l'alimentation l'énergie la santé
ou encore l'éducation
par ce texte
nous souhaitons défendre le droit des
nations à la défense de leur
identité
c'est à dire le droit des peuples à la
continuité historique et à la défense de
leur patrimoine matériel ou immatériel
par ce texte nous affirmant également le
droit des nations au bénéfice du progrès
scientifique et technique ça paraît fou
mais aujourd'hui dans la classe
politique il y a des gens qui remettent
cela en cause chaque jour des idéologies
obscurantistes du workisme à la
décroissance qui engage des dizaines de
pays avancés dans une voie technophobe
qui fait peser sur eux un danger mortel
ils veulent même
ils ne disent pas tout à fait clairement
mais on le lit entre les LIGNES privées
les pays en voie de développement du
progrès auquel chaque peuple peut
aspirer
par ce texte enfin nous affirmons le
principe de consentement au
contributions diamétralement opposées au
prélèvement et diverses contributions
qu'imposent plusieurs organisations
supranationales à leur État membre et
l'Union européenne bien sûr est à cet
égard l'une des pires incarnations de
cette réalité
le mouvement national français
par son ancienneté par sa légitimité par
sa puissance politique est fondée à
initier cette belle et grande
proposition en faveur des libertés
humaines bien loin des caricatures
bien loin des caricatures de nos
adversaires parce que parce que nous
sommes profondément français nous
n'avons pas une vision étriquée nous
n'avons pas une vision de repli notre
vision à une vocation universelle je
vous l'ai dit mille fois
mille fois lorsque nous défendons la
souveraineté de la France nous défendons
également la souveraineté de toutes les
nations du monde
oui je crois que ce texte était
essentiel nous présenterons dans toutes
les instances où nous sommes présents et
croyez moi elle commence à être
nombreuses en France avec une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle en
Europe d'abord auprès de nos alliés
européens dans le cadre de la campagne
puis dans le cas d'une proposition de
résolution au Parlement européen je le
ferai d'ailleurs dès demain auprès de la
Liga de mon ami Matteo Salvini
[Applaudissements]
ensuite je le présenterai au delà des
étapes partenaires de la France
notamment en Afrique afin de rendre à ce
grand continent les signes de
reconnaissance et de considération qui
lui ont enfin fait défauts de notre part
depuis un certain nombre d'années
vous l'avez compris chers amis la France
et l'Europe sont un tournant historique
décisif et c'est à nous
patriote français qui appartient de
donner à notre pays l'impulsion qui lui
permettra d'aborder cette nouvelle ère
avec la confiance les principes et les
outils qui lui seront indispensables
dans les prochaines décennies c'est là
le sens de notre combat jusqu'au 9 juin
prochain sur la scène européenne
diffuser cette conception de la
souveraineté de la liberté des nations à
laquelle nous sommes si profondément
attachés et nombre d'États européens
avec nous rendre aux Français les
leviers souverains qui n'auraient jamais
dû lui être confisqué en matière
économique énergétique migratoire ou
fiscale des leviers indispensables au
redressement français
redonner confiance aux dizaines de
millions de Français qui observent
chaque jour avec amertume et colère la
déliquescence de notre pays sur la scène
européenne d'accommodement renoncement
de compromission en capit population
sonner le rappel de toutes les forces
qui aujourd'hui en Europe ont compris
comme nous que le regain des nations
était la condition du maintien des liens
fraternels qui unissent tous les peuples
de notre continent à l'inverse de la
vision technocratique sans âme et à bout
de souffle que nous observons depuis
tant d'années rendra la France sa voix
particulière qui ne lui fait pas
seulement aimer passionnément la liberté
mais lui permet de créer les outils de
la liberté de toutes les nations et de
tous les peuples du monde
Jordan je sais nous savons tous ici que
tu disposes mille fois des qualités du
talent et de l'énergie qui seront
nécessaires à la conduite de ce combat
[Applaudissements]
chers amis
ça vaut très fort ce que j'ai évoqué au
début de cette intervention et c'est par
là que je vais la terminer je vais vous
redire cette vérité simple
nous sommes des millions et rien ne nous
résistera si nous restons fidèles aux
principes que nous dépendons avant avec
constance depuis des décennies car ils
n'ont jamais été d'une scie brûlante
actualité nous incarnons et vous
incarnez désormais l'espoir d'une réelle
alternance politique après 40 ans
d'erreurs stratégiques dont nous payons
le prix chaque jour par le déclassement
la pauvreté et la perte de foi en
l'avenir nous sommes prêts à endosser
cette responsabilité de redressement
national le rassemblement national était
notre maison commune en l'espace de
quelques années il est devenu celle de
millions et millions de compatriotes qui
ont compris que nos solutions et notre
constance seul constituée un espoir
solide
cette voix ne peut plus être ignorée ni
étouffé elle porte bien trop désormais
pour cela
notre objectif maintenant n'est plus
seulement d'exister mais d'exceller la
campagne des élections européennes nous
donnera l'occasion de faire vivre cette
magnifique aspiration pour que vive le
droit des peuples et des nations libres
vivent la République et vive la France
[Applaudissements]